I was raised very Catholic i'm still a
catholic and i was raised with the lives
of the saints every day we would look at
the life of a great man or woman who had
somehow you know led a good life and I
said what inspires me still are other
people I mean I meet somebody who has
spent 10 years in Africa working in a
hospital and that reminds me of that I
kind of need a better life I've got to
work harder and so I think it's you know
we learned from one another there's a
wonderful line but by by a wh auden it's
the one of its the climactic stanza of
the espera famous poem September first
1939 Ernie it goes something like all I
have is a voice to undo the folded lie
the romantic lie in the brain of a
sensual man on the street and the lie of
authority whose buildings grope the sky
and this is the lines i'm going to there
is no such thing as the state and no one
exists alone hunger allows no choice to
the citizen or the police we must love
one another or die in the notion that no
one exists alone that were part of the
human race that we have these moral
spiritual ethical obligations to each
other and that we learn from each other
and so you know what inspires me what as
far as me of people who are better than
me and most people are better than so
there's a lot of inspiration around for
me I still look at things as a Catholic
which is a which is to say that I have a
sense of the complexity and richness of
life that there is in a sense of both of
visible world and an invisible world
that the actions that we take have
consequences beyond our lives that we
are to be morally responsible for our
lives another thing that Catholicism
teaches you is is I think patience and
humility that you know that we that we
are not better than other people that we
have a responsibility to help other
people and the greatest gift of
catholicism i think is an openness to
grace does it have a sense that there
are times in your life where a grace
that comes from beyond your own life
actually pours into your life it helps
you and so is so I think of you know I'm
very much of a Mediterranean camp look
at that sense